Hello!
Ms. Coffee Bean always wanted
to ask you: How old are you?
Are you old enough to remember
those times in Computer Vision
when Autoencoders used to be the big thing?
If you remember this, then you are indeed a very
old person in Machine Learning. So be happy,
because guess what: autoencoders are
fashionable again in computer vision!
This paper combines our favorite
things: transformers, masking,
autoencoding and self-supervision in a beautifully
written paper with a simple, yet powerful idea!
So welcome to this AI Coffee Break,
where we will break down and explain the
most important contributions of this paper!
Ms. Coffee Bean, why did you bring a sponsor?
Oh, because I was running out of coffee beans
and needed money to buy some new ones? But don’t
worry, I would never use you to make my coffee.
Ok, then here we are: This video was brought
to you by Weights & Biases! If you haven’t
heard of Weights & Biases, then surely you
are living under a pile of Coffee Beans.
With Weights & Biases, you can track your
experiments and have beautiful plots at the
same time, reproduce your models and optimize
hyperparameters like a pro with Sweeps.
Say goodbye to your good old,
uninformed grid search and welcome
their integrated Bayesian optimization!
And no, you do not have to
understand this magic to use it.
There are two things I find especially impressive:
First, you can integrate Weights & Biases with
just a few lines of code, like look at this!
And secondly, it’s free for personal use
and it’s also free for academic teams!
Of course, the big players need paid
plans, but if you are a student like me
who wants to stay organized even in the advent
of the paper deadline when all your coffee
beans are going crazy and everything’s
a mess and irreproducible from that
chaotic excel spreadsheet you use for tracking
experiments, then you should give W&B a try!
Great, now let’s talk about how
and why “masked autoencoders are
[indeed] scalable vision learners”:
Hey, Ms. Coffee Bean, take it slow.
First: what is an autoencoder?
Autoencoders back in the day, were reconstructing
the input while being constrained to encode the
input into a lower dimensional space,
then reconstruct the input again.
enforced by an L2 loss, a simple
distance metric between input and output.
And because of the bottleneck in the middle
reducing the dimensionality of the data,
the hidden space is a compressed,
meaningfully packed, and efficiently
packed version of the input, or in other
words, ideally, the data manifold is learned.
So ideally, semantically similar
points are close to each other in this
space. And Autoencoders worked well in computer
vision where the image space is continuous
but were not as successful in NLP.
One of the reasons is the discrete nature of text.
Even if we often pretend that text isn’t discrete,
by representing words as vectors in word
embeddings, the in-betweenness of words,
the interpolation of (especially
context-less) words is often not
that straightforward in the same
sense it is for the visual modality.
And this is generating problems when trying
to learn the data manifold in the code space.
This then further causes problems
when computing a continuous
reconstruction loss in what
is naturally a discrete space.
But then everything changed with the introduction
of transformers doing masked autoencoding,
which happened first for NLP: Think about BERT,
which is doing what a masked autoencoder does:
it corrupts a portion of the data,
usually 15% of the tokens and BERT
learns to predict the missing content
by classifying which of all 30k or more
tokens in the English vocabulary could have
been the right word instead of the MASK token.
And we would like to do this autoencoding also
for visual data, because think about it this way:
A system that encodes data to decode it again,
not only has the advantage of self-supervision
that you do not need labelled data, because
you just take the input and reconstruct it,
but it also learns more general
representations of that modality:
Because self-supervision means that the model
is not allowed to forget everything that is not
relevant for the label of that data sample
as it is the case in supervised learning,
but needs to remember the “essence” of that data
point required to reconstruct
the entire data sample.
Only, you see, masked autoencoding which since
BERT and its likes was made easy for NLP, is now
hard for Computer Vision: The authors highlight
three key differences between vision and language.
The visual backbones used as encoders for
autoencoders, were not ready yet in the era of
CNNs: convolutional-based backbones rely on
the data regularity of image grids and it is
not easy to mask things out without introducing
artefacts in the outputs of the convolutions.
Secondly, vision and language are very
different in terms of information density.
A word is already a second-order abstraction of
the world and compactly summarizes what otherwise
is represented in many pixels in an image. Also,
information in images is much more smeared out,
because the neighborhood of some pixels
speak very much about the masked out
thing. If we do not see the eyes of
a dog, we still recognize the dog.
Whereas in language, the context is not that
verbose and the crux of the information is
mostly in the mask token. What does this mean?
Well, while masking out 15% of
tokens in language is already a lot,
masking out 15% of the pixels is
almost no corruption in images.
And thirdly, the decoding procedure is more
complicated for vision than for language.
Predicting missing words is arguably easier,
because one predicts relatively little
things with high semantic information.
For this, just a multi-layer
perceptron, or short: MLP suffices.
But when predicting pixels, one
must regress these many values,
and while caring about maintaining
contextual harmony between the many pixels.
One pixel alone carries
little semantic information,
but the whole neighbourhod of pixels, means a lot.
Therefore, it is not straightforward to do this
whole autoencoding with transformers on images, as
it is on text where the output is more compressed.
Or well, it was not straightforward until this
paper presented an elegant, simple solution:
The recipe is: Take the image and
divide it into non-overlapping patches.
These could be something like 16x16 patches.
So far, we are exactly like in the ViT setting
and we will stay in the ViT setting where
every patch is transformed into one vector,
even if it is not visualized right now in
this video. But each patch here is a vector.
To understand the prerequisites, please see
our previous videos on the Swin Transformer,
ViT and DeiT if you are not familiar
with vision transformers in general.
But now, instead of taking all these patch
vectors as input, it’s random masking time!
And by masking, it’s actually meant "removing".
Let’s say 75% of the original number of patches
are removed. Great. Then the authors take the ViT
encoder and encode only these remaining patches.
But why did they remove the patches,
instead of just masking them? Well,
because the authors are using
a transformer as an encoder.
They could have taken all image tokens,
including the masked out ones bearing
the value of the [MASK] token,
but that would blow up the sequence length,
thus compute time and memory,
because also then also
mask tokens would need to
be processed in self-attention and then by the
Feed-Forward Layer – in each transformer block.
So because the authors reduced the
sequence length of the image significantly
by just removing 75% of the
image tokens in the set,
they now can use very large encoders
by increasing the parameter number
in the feedforward networks, greatly
increasing the capacity of the encoder.
But Ms. Coffee Bean, they are completely removing
intermediate patches like they never were there
before, isn’t that confusing for the encoder?
No, because these things are almost removed like
they were not there before, because the positional
embeddings still remember the fact that this
patch is from the upper part of the image,
this other one from the second row, so
there are many positions missing there.
Thus the structure of the visual modality is
still encoded in the positional embeddings.
So the encoder with a small sequence length
processes the input and encodes it into the
latent space. And the output of the encoder
has the same number of tokens as the input has,
because the encoder is a transformer and
this is how usually transformers work.
But after training, it captures
the image semantics much better.
Ok, now it is time for decoding,
because we are in an autoencoder,
and this is where the masked
tokens are inserted again.
Because now, when reconstructing the original
image, the transformer decoder must follow
the transformer architecture: one vector
per token in, one vector per token out.
So, from the set of the (ideally) semantically
structured latent space tokens and mask tokens,
the decoder, which is also a transformer,
takes each token and computes something else,
which is ideally the original image patches.
Or almost, because to reconstruct
from vectors to the output image,
the authors again use linear projection to map
the last activations into the pixel space so
that the output of the model is an image and
the mean squared error (MSE) can be computed.
It’s important to note, that while the encoder
can be very big in terms of number of parameters
because its sequence length was significantly
reduced by removing 75% of the tokens,
the decoder operates on all patches, also on
the masked ones, thus needs to be lightweight.
And this was the masked transformer-based
autoencoder! And look, the reconstructions
look kind of blurry and Ms. Coffee Bean
thinks that one-two papers further,
this will be working for higher resolution too,
but you know, the reconstruction quality was not
the goal of this masked autoencoder anyway,
but the learned representations over here!
Representations that are already rich from
this simple masked autoencoding procedure and
do not need contrastive learning where it’s
hard to choose good negative examples and
needs image similarities, or complicated
augmentation methods like the competition
uses, such as SimCLR, MoCO, DINO, BYOL.
These representations can be used for supervised
tasks too like… ImageNet classification, yay! Or
Object Detection or semantic segmentation!
For more, check out the paper.
But what you need to know is that for
using the learned representations for
some other supervised task, possibly,
one just has to remove the decoder,
finetune some more task-specific
layers, which is easy
but it also needs to run this quite
heavyweight encoder on the unmasked image,
so on the entire image. Ms. Coffee
Bean, how large are your GPUs again?
Just two more interesting takeaways
and we’re done here, Ms. Coffee Bean:
As motivated in the beginning, while 15%
masking in textual data is noisy enough,
for images, masking more is better than
masking less and a masking ratio of 75%
empirically has been shown by
the authors to work very well.
Also, random masking is better than regular
masking, which makes sense, because the model
should have seen all possible combinations of
masks and positional encodings, or positions.
If you want to know even more about all
this, read the paper and other similar ones.
And while leaving, do not
forget to like and subscribe!
Okay, bye!